[Music]
thank you the periodic table is
instantly recognizable it's not just in
every chemistry lab worldwide it's found
on t-shirts coffee mugs and shower
curtains but the periodic table isn't
just another trendy icon it's a massive
slab of human genius up there with the
Taj Mahal the Mona Lisa and the ice
cream sandwich
and the table's Creator Dimitri
Mendeleev is a bona fide science Hall of
Famer but why what's so great about him
and his table
is it because you made a comprehensive
list of the known elements nah you don't
earn a spot in science Valhalla just for
making a list
besides Mendeleev was far from the first
person to do that
is it because Mendeleev arranged
elements with similar properties
together not really that had already
been done too
so what was mendeleev's genius let's
look at one of the first versions of the
periodic table from around 1870. here we
see elements designated by their two
letter symbols arranged in a table
check out the entry at the third column
fifth row there's a dash there from that
unassuming placeholder Springs the raw
Brilliance of Mendeleev that Dash is
science by putting that Dash there
Dimitri was making a bold statement he
said and I'm paraphrasing here you all
haven't discovered this element yet in
the meantime I'm going to give it a name
it's one step away from aluminum so
we'll call it Echo aluminum ekka being
Sanskrit for one
nobody's found ekka aluminum yet so we
don't know anything about it right wrong
based on where it's located I can tell
you all about it first of all an atom of
echo aluminum has an atomic weight of 68
about 68 times heavier than a hydrogen
atom when Echo aluminum is isolated
you'll see it's a solid metal at room
temperature it's shiny it conducts heat
really well it can be flattened into a
sheet stretched into a wire but its
melting point is low like freakishly low
oh and a cubic centimeter of it will
weigh 6 grams
Mendeleev could predict all of these
things simply from where the Blank Spot
was and his understanding of how the
elements surrounding it behaved a few
years after this prediction a french guy
named Paul Emil lacock de boss bodran
discovered a new element in ore samples
and named it gallium after Gaul the
historical name for France gallium is
one step away from aluminum on the
periodic table it's ekka aluminum so
were mendeleev's predictions right
gallium's atomic weight is 69.72
a cubic centimeter of it weighs 5.9
grams it's a solid metal at room
temperature but it melts at a paltry 30
degrees Celsius 85 degrees Fahrenheit it
melts in your mouth and in your hand not
only did Mendeleev completely nail
gallium he predicted other elements that
were unknown at the time Scandium
germanium uranium the element He called
echamanganese is now called technetium
technetium is so rare it couldn't be
isolated until it was synthesized in a
cyclotron in 1937 almost 70 years after
Dimitri predicted its existence
thirty years after he died
Dimitri died without a Nobel Prize in
1907 but he wound up receiving a much
more exclusive honor in 1955 scientists
at UC Berkeley successfully created 17
atoms of a previously undiscovered
element
this element filled an empty spot in the
periodic table at number 101 and was
officially named mendelevium in 1963.
there have been well over 800 Nobel
Prize winners but only 15 scientists
have an element named after them
so the next time you stare at a periodic
table whether it's on the wall of a
university classroom or on a five dollar
coffee mug Dimitri Mendeleev the
architect of the periodic table will be
staring back
foreign